[Música]
pasamos ahora al repaso económico del
día junto Juan Pablo lucum y Juan Pablo
saludo nuevamente para usted aquí
estamos otra vez y para hablar
precisamente de una de las noticias del
día que son las movilizaciones más
grandes en una década en el Reino Unido
por favor Qué dicen los manifestantes
Ángela Pues de forma general los
funcionarios de distintos sectores le
piden al gobierno Un aumento salarial
que sea coherente con la inflación y
mejores condiciones laborales el índice
de precios al consumidor alcanzó el
10,5% interanual en diciembre la tasa
más alta en 40 años y el país sigue
viviendo momentos históricos porque la
semana pasada también se dio otra huelga
inédita cuando por primera vez en la
historia británica los empleados de
Amazon protestaron esto al centro de
Inglaterra
Además de eso Ángela Hoy hay medio
millón de británicos Pues si ellos
salieron a las calles ellos dijeron
también esto en Pues escuchemos
estamos todos juntos en esto porque
todos merecemos un mejor trato Y si el
gobierno no hace algo al respecto creo
que veremos más días como hoy con más y
más sindicatos uniéndose
estamos pidiendo un aumento salarial a
prueba de la inflación de dos dígitos
para evitar que el salario de los
maestros se siga recortando este año
También queremos un reajuste salarial de
los maestros a largo plazo teniendo en
cuenta que la mayor cantidad de horas
extra que se trabaja no son remuneradas
más grandes pero definitivamente no es
algo nuevo hemos visto varias
manifestaciones a lo largo de las
últimas semanas y meses cuál es la
respuesta del gobierno pues exactamente
el 27 de enero el secretario de economía
Jeremy Holmes presentó su plan para
sacar a Reino Unido de la crisis
económica aquí en gran parte se debe a
los primeros o a los problemas de los
primeros ministros anteriores con los
escándalos de políticos de Boris Johnson
y el polémico mini presupuesto del
strust reducir la inflación a la mitad
hacer que la economía Pues también
crezca y reducir la deuda son algunas de
las opciones que el gobierno ha
presentado bajo este proyecto nuevas
prioridades o nuestras prioridades tus
prioridades el de hacer crecer la
economía lo han planteado como volver a
Reino Unido un silicon Valley en tema de
inversión para las empresas y pues ha
pedido ayuda también de los inversores
de manera general este plano y el último
que es de tener los barcos se han
enfocado sobre todo en el tema de la
migración para tratar de tener la
migración que es pues elevada en Reino
Unido Ya lo hemos visto también
esto mientras que estamos después el día
después del aniversario 3 desde el
brexit Pero bueno vamos a cambiar de
tema porque también hay otro aniversario
y es en myanmar dos años desde el último
golpe militar que derrocó el gobierno
civil de a un Samsung revisemos cómo
está el país en cifras en este momento
Juan Pablo Ángeles precisamente Hoy hace
unos minutos el jefe de la junta de
Villamar dijo que alargará seis meses
más el estado de emergencia en el que se
encuentra el país mientras según él
trabajará para celebrar elecciones este
miércoles miles salieron a protestar en
frente de la embajada birmana en la
capital tailandesa el año pasado la
represión realizó los primeros cuatro
ejecuciones a condenados a muerte que el
país vivía en décadas mientras por lo
menos 101 personas han sido condenadas a
la pena capital 130 periodistas han sido
arrestados de los cuales 72 siguen en
prisión lo que Ubica mi amar en el
puesto 176 de 180 en el índice de
libertad de prensa según reporteros Sin
fronteras y vamos a mirar también unas
de esas cifras que tenemos a
continuación y es 1,5 millones de
personas desplazadas esto un informe que
da el alto comisionado de las Naciones
Unidas para los refugiados casi 14.000
detenidos por motivos políticos un dato
que da la asociación para la asistencia
de presos políticos y 3000 de ellos
también muertos a manos de las fuerzas
del orden 14.000 detenidos y casi 3000
muertos el pib en 2021 bajó a estuvo en
18% es un dato del Banco Mundial
1,1 millones de desempleados más que
hace dos años 15,2 millones de hermanos
padecen de inseguridad alimentaria y el
último dato uno de los más preocupantes
que lo decíamos Es casi la población de
Bogotá o de Ciudad de México que es 7,8
millones de niños que no están
escolarizados un dato de amnistía
internacional
vaya a cambiar Próximamente Ya cambiando
de tema quisiera pedirle que nos cuente
que nos espera para hoy en términos de
indicadores hoy en temas económicos hay
dos datos que están riendo la jornada
Uno de ellos es la reunión del
presidente Joe biden con el presidente
de la cámara de representantes que vive
mccarthy para definir el tema del techo
de la deuda ya el tesoro también se
pronunció pero otro de los grandes es la
reunión de la reserva Federal que se
espera que suba 25 puntos básicos pues
esto las tasas de interés que deje puede
subir de manera crítica las tasas de
interés los tipos de interés esto
también definió hoy cómo estuvieron las
jornadas y en Asia básicamente
estuvieron en colores azul como lo
podemos ver en la pantalla esperando que
los datos de la reserva Federal sea tal
cual como lo dijimos las bolsas en
Europa siguen operando mayoritariamente
en terreno positivo esto después de
conocerse que la inflación de la zona
Euro cayó por tercer mes consecutivo
paso del 9,2% anual de diciembre al 8,5%
anual en enero y su cifra del día que
está animada por el fin de las
restricciones de covid Así es
882,5% subió la facturación bruta
derivada del juego de casinos en Macao
un dato interanual de enero que se da
tras el final de las restricciones
derivadas de la política de cero covid
Macao se encuentra junto a la provincia
de cantona 70 kilómetros del suroeste en
Hong Kong esto en China Juan Pablo
Gracias a ustedes por la actualización
de las noticias económicas y nos vemos
mañana mañana con mucho más gracias